we started the chicken experience in
2004 to really be proactive and focus on
the two kids that were in the pet trade
the culture in Costa Rica was always
that animals could be caught and they
could be kept as pets
unfortunately Costa Rica changed those
laws and said no wild animal can be a
pet we've diversified into you know all
kinds of different wildlife really
because of the demand that was put upon
us
Costa Rica is just an incredible country
the forest is very much alive
but this life is under threat the
wildlife is impacted because of the
plantations because of farming and
because of human encroachment in a year
we'll receive approximately 450 animals
and of that roughly 40% will be released
the ones that aren't released are
animals with injuries or there are also
animals that psychologically can't go
out because they're too imprinted on
humans during the last five years we've
been receiving so many more sloths
especially baby sloths right now we have
15 in our care and it's so difficult to
be thinking about okay what are these
lots need to get them back into the wild
it's so rewarding to see you know the
progress that they make the trust that
those animals give us is just amazing as
they get better they're letting us know
hey I'm getting better and by the time
they're like bumping you know on the
side of the cage or like it's saying you
know I'm ready to be out
that's like pure joy for us because we
know that we've accomplished what I set
out to do the long-term perspective for
rescuing animals in Costa Rica is
actually really hopeful because we're
doing the education we're setting the
foundation with the Wildlife Department
with the children in the schools we're
facing all these threats right now as a
planet and there's going to be lots of
changes and lots of impact and the more
people that we can get involved in this
type of work the better it's going to be
in the long run for everybody
you